wir haben hier einfach das ist so ja so
eine art knete mit der das auto reinigen
kannst du doch speziell in zwischenräume
immer ganz viele verschiedene wird man
so ein bisschen für hey was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch jedes gut
mir auch es ist nur extrem warm es ist
wirklich sehr sehr warm und ich setze
hier morgen regnet es wieder gewinnungs
wieder und ich nehme trotzdem heute bei
30 grad auf die rollade darunter gemacht
dieses video auf und es ist trotzdem
immer noch wahr obwohl ach ja auf jeden
fall gibt es heute einen weiteren part
von tik tok made me by bis oder produkte
die ich gekauft habe weil ich sie auf
tik tok gesehen habt ihr haben wir da
wirklich extrem leise und hilfreiche
sachen dabei deswegen lohnt es sich dran
zu bleiben eine sache die ich vor sagen
wollte beziehungsweise euch fragen wollt
wenn ihr irgendwelche ideen habt für
videos die ihr gerne sehen würde oder
produkte die ich bestellen soll
irgendwie eine bestimmte kategorie oder
so schreibe es in die kommentare
seit gern kreativ und ich lese mir das
alles durch weil er sich überlegt auch
so ein bisschen was man noch machen kann
dann würde ich sagen wie lange man gar
nicht lange
checkt mal das erste produkt ab und das
ist folgendes
also ich muss wirklich sagen das habe
ich gesehen und ich habe es direkt
bestellt ich habe schon so oft das
problem dass du irgendwie eine
trinkflasche in der hand halten muss ist
weil halt wasser drin war oder was vor
dem restaurant vielleicht noch ein
bisschen was unter dem getränk drin
hatte und es nicht trinken konnte oder
halt dann auch nicht mitnehmen konnte
und deshalb habe ich diese faltbare
trinkflasche bestellt von unter ja keine
ahnung am anfang dachte ich dass es so
eine zauber flasche also ich habe noch
weitere tipps dazu gesehen wo du halt
flüssigkeiten rein fühlen kannst und die
dann trotzdem wieder zusammen falten
kann es aber irgendwann habe ich dann
auch mal logisch nachgedacht und bin zum
entschluss gekommen dass das
physikalisch nicht möglich ist aber
erhältst du bin ich nicht deswegen ja
hier steht es untendrunter ihr könnt es
wahrscheinlich nicht erkennt aber hier
steht 5 150 milliliter passen da rein
ich dachte eigentlich man kann die noch
mehr zusammen falten nicht auf jeden
fall ein bisschen ja das ist schon sehr
nach chemie aber was sie darauf made
entscheider oder natürlich wir können
hier dann ganz einfach mal auseinander
ziehen und dann sieht man wie es schon
relativ groß
also ein bisschen platz sparen ist das
und dann natürlich auch jahr
zusammenbrauen also da hat sich wirklich
jemand was bei gedacht das finde ich gut
ich weiß halt nur nicht ob das sich so
krass lohnt man müsste es eigentlich
noch mehr falten können schon mal kurz
eine flasche junge leute zieht jetzt mal
aus und kippt das bisschen wasser rein
sagt jetzt ist sie auf jeden fall fast
bis oben hin voll machen wir die zu und
man könnte jetzt theoretisch ganz
einfach austrinken mache ich jetzt nicht
weil ich habe die vorher nicht
durchgespielt das machst du dann hier
drauf registers zu und jetzt kannst du
das so ein bisschen noch
auf die stufe stellen wie viel wasser
halt ja gut es ist zu viel aber wenn
jetzt halt ein bisschen weniger drin wer
moment wir machen das ist mal wieder
lehrer dann kann man das halt zusammen
falten und jetzt hast du halt so viel
was hat er es ist schon also man kann
damit was anfangen ich weiß nicht ob man
das gebrauchen kann alle sachen denn wie
immer in der video beschreibung verlinkt
die hat glaube ich so 12 euro oder so
gekostet schreibt gehen wir eure meinung
dazu in die kommentare
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt und das ist folgendes
[Musik]
also auf dem video sei das schon extrem
leises ich weiß nicht ob das ding was
ich bestellt habe auch diese qualität
hat und ob man hier ja auch dieses
ergebnis erzielen kann vielleicht wird
das video im nachhinein du bist ja mal
arbeitet aber wir schenken das mal ab
also ich hab hier folgendes bestellt
made in china natürlich dream like
rotating projekt was ist heute los
voting project das herz welcher rotating
projekt rotating project project for
taking projekten
jetzt haben wir es ja okay sagt mal auch
klar also ich glaube das produkt was
hier im video hatten sagen ganz bisschen
anders aus aber davon gibt es ganz viele
verschiedene ausführungen und
verschiedene muster ok also wir haben
hier jetzt glaube ich diesen die muss
glaube ich drauf bleiben
ich weiß es gar wir haben hier jetzt
diesen sternenhimmel darauf könnt ihr
hier sehen und ja mal gucken ich bin
wirklich gespannt also wir machen hier
ist vielleicht mal das licht auf ok sie
bitte einmal licht aus hey leute was
geht ab ich hoffe ihr könnt mich noch
sehen ich habe jetzt diese lampe mal
angelassen und wir machen das jetzt mal
an
hahaha ich mache mal das licht hier auch
aus also hier hinten hat man so
verschiedene knöpfe da kann man dann das
muster wechseln und die farbe aroma die
farbe wechselt auch jetzt hier und es
bewegt sich sogar jetzt kann ich sogar
bewegen das ist nice das war halt nur so
ein leises nerviges geräusche
guck mal ganz viele verschiedene ja
schon irgendwie nice da wird man so ein
bisschen
so das sind wir wieder also man kann
über diese drei knöpfe einfach so ein
bisschen vorstellen oder dann kommen wir
ganz viele verschiedene verrückte muster
warum ich muss sagen ich glaube schon
wenn man so im bett liegt und sich das
ankur wieso sich die sterne und der mond
bewegen ist das schon beruhigen also
auch jetzt muss ich sagen feiere ich
kann ich weiter empfehlen wir machen
aber weiter mit dem nächsten produkt und
das
bist du wirklich bis heute nicht dass es
so etwas gibt ich habe das so
morgens und kaffee macht und erst nach
20 minuten wieder eiskalt und du
vergisst halt immer dann zu trinken wer
kennt es nicht also an die älteren von
euch kennt das doch oder deswegen habe
ich mich auch hier verpflichtet gefühlt
dieses produkt zu erstellen wir haben
hier ein usb capra sieben euro glaube
ich also ja okay ist ja an sich selbst
erklärend das ding und schließt man an
mit dem usb-anschluss hier und dann wird
das warm oder wahrscheinlich sogar sehr
heiß und dann kann man halt die tasse
drauf stellen die dann für immer war
bleibt ich weiß nun nicht kommen hier
ist so ja so die nennt man das so zeugs
drauf wenn das heißt wir das ist doch
nicht gesund oder na ja man muss es
ausprobieren ganz gut ich habe dafür
jetzt einfach mal ein macbook und
schließt es hier an
naja us werte tatsächlich 8
hey ich bin wirklich so jung wie kann
man wie kann man eigentlich so blöd sein
wie ich dachte das ding muss um es muss
natürlich so rum und hier kommt dann die
taste drauf und ich merke auch jetzt
schon diese fläche wird zunehmend schwül
heiß haben
ich demonstriere ich das mal ganz kurz
in diesem zimmer ist das so heißt
genauso wie das war ja es ist schon arg
heißt also man sollte weiß ja nicht
drauf passen
ich stelle hier mal die taste drauf mit
kaltem wasser und wir warten noch ein
bisschen ob das auch schnell
funktioniert aber an sich muss ich
wirklich sagen es gibt so viele sachen
von denen weiß man nicht dass sie
existieren und sie sind wirklich
hilfreich ich bin nur noch nicht so ganz
überzeugt dass das auch schnell
funktioniert wir schauen uns in der
zwischenzeit einfach schon mal das
nächste produkt an was ich bestellt
haben oder drücken so lange auf diesen
dingern hier wollen wir das auch super
leute das trifft sie wirklich ganz gut
die nächsten beiden gadgets muss ich bei
einem auto ausprobieren also zumindest
bietet sich das an wir haben hier
einfach das ist so ja so eine art knete
mit der das auto reinigen kannst oder
speziellen so zwischenräume im auto
gelangen kannst um die halle zu reinigen
geht natürlich auch für küche und so ich
bin mal gespannt ob das also was es mit
der knete macht weil die ist ja
irgendwann dann trocknen das habe ich
auf jeden fall noch bestellt und das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal an dafür muss
ich ins auto legen mal runter was geht
ab wir sind jetzt hier im auto ich habe
das schon ausgepackt wir haben jetzt die
super clean sourcing made in china
natürlich auch auf jeden fall ein
oder ist gerade hinter der kamera der
film das jetzt das hier ist sozusagen
reinigungs knete fürs auto das heißt
wenn man hier irgendwie sorgen die
zwischenräume muss kann man einfach
diese reinigungs knete benutzen du
kannst ein mal hier unten hilfe zb sieht
man ja ein bisschen dreckig da ne also
jetzt unter schauen wir mal ob das denn
easy damit werk geht ich mache das
einfach mal auf meinem auto springen
könnt in deinem auto ist ist weniger
ich kann mir das gerne gleich aussehen
also was ich mich halt wie gesagt nur
frage ist ob man die dann auch wieder
reinigen kann oder nicht also wir machen
das jetzt wohl dass hier mal raus für
sich
ich bin ziemlich gut riecht sogar noch
irgendwie so eine creme die richter hat
ist infektion
wir machen das jetzt einfach mal so wie
im video gesehen hier über das lenkrad
ob das denn wirklich so funktioniert das
geht ja also im video haben wir das ja
hier so darüber gestülpt vielleicht habe
ich da auch das falsche keine ahnung
egal
wir gehen jetzt einfach mal rüber das
ding ist halt immer wenn ich jetzt
drüber gehe mit der knete so in die
zwischenräume oder so sagt sagt wo so
geht's jetzt aber wenn man so rüber
schaaf dann bleiben hier überall so
fußgängerzone ist ja kein scheiß dachte
das passiert halt gerade nicht also
eigentlich hab ich mir das wirklich
besser vorgestellt wir drücken das jetzt
mal hier in die zwischenräume und jetzt
mal hier unten hin
woher gut so funktioniert schon dein
auto kann jeder gerufen haben wichtig
ist dass man diese knete nicht so reibt
man darf die nur so ganz locker fluffig
hier so lange schieben und dann
funktioniert hat auch der bildschirm
davon aus dass der bildschirm
ich hätte da hingehen also ich weiß
nicht es wird auf jeden fall damit alles
sauberer das kann man deutlich erkennen
ob ich das jetzt so einen ganz normalen
staubtuch oder so bevorzugen würde oder
generell halt so ein putztuch weiß ich
nicht also probiert selber aus ich finde
es jetzt nicht schlecht aber so mega es
ist es jetzt auch nicht mit höchstens
zehn euro
es ist halt einfach mal was anderes weil
so schleimig ist ne da ist gut aber wir
wollen ja das ist gut so gut mache
weiter mit dem nächsten produktion was
ich noch ganz gut sagen wollte
die ist jetzt hier schon deutlich also
endlos putzen damit geht wahrscheinlich
nicht willkommen zurück einige zeit ist
auf jeden fall jetzt verstrichen ich
habe jetzt mal einen finger rein
gehalten in die tasse und es ist ein
bisschen wärmer geworden es ist jetzt
allerdings nicht heiß oder so ein
bisschen können sie auch an der kasse
liegen weil die sich hier unten so ab
also die hat so brandt und die wird
nicht komplett erhitzt aber ich denke
wenn man den kaffee durchgehend darauf
stehen hat bleibt er auch durchgehend
heißt
funktioniert schon meine sache habe ich
noch und zwar wer von euch hätte nicht
auch gerne seinen eigenen rolls royce
und einen rolls royce zeichnet sich auch
durch diese deckenbeleuchtung aus da
sind ja dann so rutscht er auch so eine
art sternenhimmel glaube ich und darauf
bezieht sich das nächste tik tok wir
schauen uns gut also es könnte
vielleicht ein bisschen billig über
kommen das weiß ich nicht aber dafür
test mehr aus und scheiße ich kann das
gar nicht jetzt machen weil das müsste
dafür dunkel sein
das ist ein bisschen blöd aber gar kein
problem dann warten wir halt bis heute
abend eigentlich soll das video heute
kommen aber verschiebt sich dann halt
auch morgen okay leute wir sind immer
noch im auto habe ich euch ja gesagt und
hier ist jetzt dass rolls royce
lichtkünstlers mehr denn im rolls royce
da ist auch immer hier die decke so
beleuchtet und wenn man ein rolls royce
auf wunsch bestellt dann geht das
nämlich so aus das ist ganz einfach wird
erstmal beschreibung bei aber das ist
ein und lernt ja leute das ist
voraussetzung ihr braucht natürlich
einen usb anschluss oder einen
zigarettenanzünder an dem ein usb
adapter dran ist ich habe
glücklicherweise hier in meinem auto
einen usb-anschluss und ich würde sagen
wir stecken das jetzt mal rein
das problem ist halt gerade ist das hält
weswegen wir wahrscheinlich noch ein
bisschen warten müssen aber ich probiere
es trotzdem aus schlüssel nicht im
fahrzeug russen der schlüssel für skoda
eine romanisten was angegangen gerade
nicht karl c nicht unter umständen und
man sieht deshalb eine sequenz das
muster ein bisschen vorstellen
also würde ich sie so rum fahren nein
definitiv nicht
aber wenn es jetzt ganz dunkel ist
könnte es schon leicht aussehen das ding
ist halt das blendet haben heute ich
würde sagen es mitunter sagen ja und
kannst du wahrscheinlich nicht so gut
ach ja das ist ja so ein laserpointer
also ich könnte euch hier gern noch mal
ein foto ein wie es aussieht wenn wir
nacht haben
ich muss sagen ich glaube auch nicht
dass es erlaubt ist wenn man angehalten
wird und die polizei 15 uhr hat
laserpointer sieht und wirklich so nice
ist das jetzt auch nicht also es geht
schon billig auch das hier ist jetzt
auch ein auto was ein ziemlich kleinen
innenraum hat vielleicht das suv oder so
ein nice aber kann ich ja auch nicht
vorstellen er halt eine höhere decke hat
also hier muss ich sagen dass es
definitiv einen flop und das kann ich
euch nicht empfiehlt das waren jetzt
zehn euro für die mülltonne habe ich mir
schon gedacht
heute dann soviel erstmal dazu ich hoffe
das video hat euch wie immer gefallen
ich würde mich mega über den daumen nach
oben freut abonniert sehr gerne den
kanal und schreibt ideen für weitere
videos in die kommentare was euch
bestellen was soll ich besser nicht
bestellt noch einen anderen kanal ob
alex v und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
video wieder rein